في العراق مؤخرا في ظاهره لتسريب الرسائل
والقرارات الرسميه ونشر صور منها على
المنصه ويبدون الحكومه طفشت من هذا
الموضوع وقررت انها تحط له حد فقامت
الحكومه اصدرت خطاب رسمي تحديدا من مكتب
رئيسها محمد شويع السوداني وفي بتوجه
مؤسسات الدوله بمعاقبه الموظفين المسؤولين
عن تسريب الوفاء الرسميه ومحاسبه كل شخص
يتغاضى عن المخالفات وما يطبق العقوبات
بحقهم لكن اشيل كوميدي اللي صار حقيقه انه
خطاب منع تسريب الوفاق الرسميه هو نفسه
هذا يتسرب وعليه واتساب وفيسبوك وتويتر
العراقين جالسين بيتداول وصور الخطاب بنصه
وترويسته وتوقيع اللي عليه كمان وطبعا ما
يحتاج يقول لكم انه الموضوع تحول لكم ماده
اساسيه ليه سخريه العراقيين على المنصات